Depuis des siècles, certains
affirment que leur vie a été enrichie
par les esprits
d'un univers supérieur.
Qu'ils guident,
mettent en garde ou soignent,
ces apparitions d'êtres célestes
auraient sauvé et transformé des vies.
Aujourd'hui, alors que notre
monde subit des bouleversements
plus profonds que jamais,
ces phénomènes paraissent se multiplier.
Partager les larmes,
la joie et la sérénité
qui marquent ces histoires
véridiques, voici les anges gardiens.
En dépit de milliers
d'années d'investigation,
les anges restent un mystère.
Pour certains, ils ne sont
qu'un fruit de notre imagination,
mais pour un grand nombre
d'entre nous, ils sont bien réels.
Je fais partie de ces millions
de gens qui s'y intéressent de près.
Tableaux, sculptures,
bijoux, livres, calendriers,
tout prouve que l'intérêt
qu'on leur porte ne cesse de croître.
Une chanson sur
dix contient le mot ange.
Aujourd'hui, ils sont plus nombreux
qu'ils ne l'ont jamais été dans l'histoire
à dire avoir eu un contact
direct avec des anges
et leur vie en a été transformée.
Les anges occupent une place
très importante dans ma vie.
Que leur forme soit terrestre ou éthérée,
ils parcourent la terre
sans bruit et répandent l'espoir.
Un ange est apparu à mon chevet.
Je le voyais très bien,
il était lumière,
mais ce dont je me souviens
surtout, ce sont ses ailes.
La religion n'a jamais été fait pour moi,
mais sans aucun doute, c'était un ange.
J'étais en larmes et tout à coup,
j'ai senti une main sur mon front
et j'ai entendu,
ne t'inquiète pas Hélène
et j'ai su que j'étais
en présence d'un ange.
J'allais mourir,
je tremblais de fièvre.
Puis la fièvre est tombée
et j'ai entendu une voix,
n'aie crainte,
car je suis toujours avec toi.
J'ai trouvé cela effrayant
au début, mais ce n'est pas effrayant.
Les anges me disaient
que je pouvais aller là ou là-bas,
où je voulais,
c'est moi qui choisissais.
Il arrive qu'un patient
à qui l'on a fait un diagnostic
malheureusement très inquiétant et qui
a décidé de ne suivre aucun traitement.
Réapparaissent
deux à cinq ans plus tard
et vous dises docteur,
je suis toujours vivant.
Il y a des choses
qu'on ne peut pas expliquer.
Miracle, ange, appelez-les comme
vous voudrez qui aident vraiment les gens.
Lorsque vous avez connu un ange,
lorsqu'un ange vous a sauvé la vie,
que vous avez regardé
un ange dans les yeux,
rien n'est plus comme avant.
Certains disent que les anges délivrent
des messages concernant l'avenir.
Parfois, ces prédictions
apportent la joie et le bonheur,
parfois la tragédie et le désespoir.
Nous étions une famille très unie et
notre vie entière reposait sur la famille
La perte d'un élément de celle-ci
nous avait accablés de douleur.
Le 18 août 1982,
le malheur frappe la famille Moore
lorsque Tara, leur fille de 15 ans,
meurt dans un accident de la route
près de leur domicile
à Laguna Hills, en Californie.
Les Moore expliquent que cette tragédie
leur avait été prédite par plusieurs
messages adressés par des anges.
Deux ou trois mois avant l'accident,
j'ai dit que notre vie allait changer.
Je ne savais pas ce que je voulais
dire, mais c'est l'impression que j'avais.
Sandy et Kirk Moore
ont remarqué que leur fille
a changé plusieurs
semaines avant l'accident.
Elle s'était soudain
passionnée pour les anges.
Elle avait acheté un livre sur
les anges et c'était devenu sa bible.
Elle l'emportait partout,
nous l'avons toujours,
il est tout corné et contient
ce qu'elle écrivait à ses anges.
On a découvert dans ses cahiers
d'école qu'elle leur posait les questions.
Sur une page, il y a un problème
de math et sur celle d'à côté,
on peut lire, ange,
que pensez-vous de cela ?
Ange, aidez-moi !
Une force angélique semble
guider Tara sur une nouvelle voie.
On a remarqué
des choses inhabituelles
au cours des deux
ou trois semaines avant l'accident.
Tara était partie dans un camp
d'adolescent avec sa petite sœur Deanna.
Pendant son séjour, elle avait peint
pour nous deux anges en céramique.
L'un d'eux pleurait.
Cela ne ressemblait pas à Tara
et dans le camp, les autres
l'appelaient la fille aux anges.
Les messages angéliques
continuent d'inonder la maison des Moore.
Lorsque Tara rentre de vacances,
elle donne à sa sœur Deanna
le livre sur les anges
auquel elle tient tant.
Je me souviens
de la joie de Deanna
lorsqu'elle m'a dit que Tara
lui avait donné son livre préféré
et qu'elle serait
toujours son ange gardien.
Je sais qu'elle croyait
beaucoup aux anges.
J'étais sa petite sœur alors
je voulais y croire moi aussi.
À ce moment-là, les parents
de Tara n'ont pas conscience
que les anges sont autant
d'indices sur le destin de leur fille,
destin qui leur sera
dévoilé deux jours plus tard.
Elle avait fait des burritos
pour ses amis et sa sœur Deanna
pour une soirée entre filles.
Elle m'a regardée, ses amies
étaient assises autour de la table
et elle m'a demandée que quand
on avait fini son travail dans cette vie,
est-ce qu'on peut partir pour
travailler dans une vie supérieure ?
Je me souviens qu'elle m'a regardée
droit dans les yeux avec insistance.
Puis, on a recommencé
à rire et à s'amuser.
C'était sa façon de me
dire que mon heure est venue,
j'ai quelque chose
de plus important à faire.
Un peu plus tard dans la soirée,
Tara sort avec deux de ses amis,
assurant à sa mère
qu'elle revient bientôt.
Kirk est rentré
ce soir-là en retard
et m'a dit qu'il y avait eu un très
grave accident en bas de la rue.
J'ai su tout de suite ce qui
s'était passée, j'en étais certaine.
Alors je lui ai dit que, Kirk,
c'était Tara, il fallait qu'on y aille.
Le véhicule que conduit l'ami
de Tara heurte un camion garé
sur le bord
d'une route mal éclairée.
Ses deux amis en
réchappent, mais pas Tara.
Je me souviens avoir pensé
à tout ce qu'on avait prévu
de faire ensemble
et qu'on ne ferait jamais.
On devait vivre
dans des maisons voisines.
Elle devait m'adopter avec son
petit ami pour que je sois leur fille.
Ce genre de bêtise
Les Moore sont accablés
de douleur par la mort de Tara.
Le lendemain matin, ils découvrent
d'autres indices angéliques
et ils se demandent si Tara
ne connaissait pas son destin.
Le lendemain de l'accident, nous
avons trouvé sur le sol de sa chambre
les paroles d'une chanson
intitulée, Tu es un ange.
Dans la cuisine, le jour suivant,
il y avait un biscuit en forme d'ange.
Un biscuit en forme
d'ange que Tara avait fait,
je ne sais pas
où elle avait trouvé la pâte.
Ni l'emporte-pièce.
On a su que c'était sa façon
de nous dire qu'elle nous aimait
et qu'elle était partie pour d'autres
tâches et être avec les anges.
Pour les Moore, Tara sera
toujours la petite fille pleine de vie,
qui chantait, dansait
et remplissait leur vie de joie.
Aujourd'hui, dans la
souffrance et le chagrin,
ils ont reçu le réconfort
des anges de Tara.
Une des choses
les plus précieuses de ma vie,
c'était la relation
que j'avais avec Tara.
Si elle était inquiète, contrariée,
je lui disais toujours que j'allais
lui faire traverser cette épreuve.
C'était notre expression.
Depuis sa mort, les Moore pensent que Tara
est devenue l'ange gardien de la famille.
Sa grand-mère
se souvient qu'un soir,
Tara est apparue devant
elle dans un moment difficile.
Ce week-end-là, Sandy, Deannna
et Kirk étaient partis à Arrowhead.
Ils devaient être rentrés depuis
deux heures et j'étais morte d'inquiétude.
J'ai levé les yeux et j'ai vu Tara
vêtue de l'une de ses
robes que j'aimais beaucoup.
Elle m'a dit qu'elle était venue
pour me faire traverser cette épreuve
et qu'ils allaient arriver.
Ensuite, j'ai entendu un
bruissement et elle a disparu.
À travers la mort de Tara, les anges ont
changé la vie des Moore à tout jamais.
Nous avons tellement été
touchés par les signes angéliques
que Tara nous avait laissés, qu'ils
sont devenus le centre de notre vie.
Nos amis ont commencé
à nous offrir des cadeaux,
des livres sur les anges et peu à peu,
ils ont rempli notre existence.
Les Moore comprennent que les anges
présents dans leur vie sont un signe.
Sandy et Kirk abandonnent leur carrière
et mettant tous leurs
espoirs dans les anges,
ouvrent une boutique en l'honneur
de leurs filles, Les Anges de Tara.
Ce magasin,
situé à San Juan Capistrano,
contient tous les cadeaux
angéliques que l'on peut imaginer.
Nous voulions garder l'amour
et la mémoire de Tara vivant.
Sa mort aurait été absurde
si nous n'étions pas parvenus à
renverser la situation et à la positiver.
Avec la boutique,
nous pensons y avoir réussi.
Les gens nous disent
qu'ils s'y sentent bien.
Venant des quatre coins du pays,
les clients ne veulent pas
qu'acheter un livre ou une figurine.
Ils espèrent aussi bénéficier
de la guérison spirituelle
que leur procure la boutique.
Un homme est entré,
il venait de perdre sa femme.
Il voulait quelque chose
d'unique pour ses petits-enfants.
Nous avons parlé,
le message est de nouveau passé
et c'est comme cela que tous les jours,
l'histoire de notre guérison
et des anges aide les gens à guérir.
Nous n'avons pas
le sentiment de l'avoir perdu.
Je sais que Tara et ses
anges jouent un grand rôle
dans notre vie désormais
et dans celle de bien d'autres gens.
Son heure était venue d'avoir une autre
existence dans une sphère supérieure.
Les cendres de Tara
ont été répandues dans la mer,
près d'un endroit
où je fais du surf.
Lorsque je surfe là-bas,
je me sens en communion.
Je sais qu'il y a des anges
là-haut qui font du surf avec moi.
Ma planche est assez
longue pour accueillir un ange.
Qui sont ou que sont
ces anges ? Ont-ils des ailes ?
Combien sont-ils ? Un être
humain peut-il devenir un ange ?
Les questions sont aussi
vieilles que les anges eux-mêmes.
Le premier document mentionnant
les anges remonte à 10 000 ans.
Depuis, l'histoire fourmille
de récits contradictoires.
Le mot ange
signifie messager de Dieu,
un lien nécessaire
entre l'homme et son Créateur.
Dieu est trop imposant, trop puissant,
trop écrasant pour apparaître en personne.
Il est dit dans la Bible,
les hommes ne peuvent m'affronter
face à face et continuer à vivre.
Dieu l'a dit à Moïse
et je pense que les anges
symbolisent le besoin psychologique
d'avoir en quelque sorte un sas.
Dans toutes les grandes religions,
les anges ont un rôle important.
Dans le judaïsme, ce sont
les anges qui guidèrent Abraham
et aidèrent Moïse
à aller vers la Terre promise.
Dans le christianisme,
c'est l'archange Gabriel
qui annonça à Marie
qu'elle enfanterait Jésus.
Ce sont les anges
qui firent rouler la pierre,
qui scellait le tombeau
et accompagnèrent le Christ au ciel.
Dans la religion islamique, les anges
sont présents dans les mosquées
et écoutent les prières des fidèles.
C'est là aussi Gabriel qui apparut
à Mahomet et lui inspira le Coran.
Les religions orientales ont
également un élément angélique.
Il existe des personnages
angéliques dans le bouddhisme
et je dirais que la plupart des religions
ont des personnages
plus ou moins extraterrestres.
Bien que la plupart des religions
reconnaissent l'existence des anges,
les contradictions concernant
leur nature sont légion.
Prenons les ailes, par exemple,
dans l'Ancien Testament, il est
fréquent que les anges n'en aient pas.
Nous savons qu'autrefois, ce n'étaient
pas des personnages avec des ailes.
C'étaient des messagers de Dieu
apparaissant dans divers lieux.
Nous en avons les preuves.
Ils ne ressemblaient pas
aux anges baroques
qu'on accroche de
nos jours aux arbres de Noël.
À d'autres époques,
les anges avaient bien des ailes,
comme ceux qui ont visité Ézéchiel.
La Bible les décrit ainsi,
ils avaient une ressemblance humaine.
Chacun avait quatre visages
et chacun avait quatre ailes
et l'aspect de ces êtres vivants
ressemblait à des charbons ardents.
Au Moyen Âge, ce sont les artistes qui
ont rendu les ailes quasi obligatoires,
car les utilisaient pour distinguer
les anges des êtres humains.
Quand un être a des ailes, ce n'est pas
la peine d'être un spécialiste du cerveau
pour comprendre que celles-ci
suggèrent l'envol, la capacité à voler.
À évoluer dans les airs, à être
au-dessus du sol sur lequel nous vivons.
On peut dire que l'ange transcende la vie
ordinaire, c'est un personnage important.
Autre mystère, le nombre d'anges.
Les textes anciens parlaient de plusieurs
centaines, mais dès le Moyen Âge,
certains théologiens donnèrent
un chiffre exact 301 655 722.
On se demandait aussi combien d'anges
pouvaient tenir dans une tête d'épingle.
Ils n'avaient tout
simplement jamais vu d'anges
alors ils théorisaient
et ils rivalisaient.
C'était à celui qui formulerait
la théorie la plus imaginative.
Aujourd'hui encore, on se demande
si le nombre d'anges augmente.
Si vous et moi pouvons espérer en
devenir un, certains disent que oui.
Peut-être nous transformons-nous
en anges après notre mort,
après plusieurs vies,
plusieurs morts.
Nous ne savons pas
ce qui se passe de l'autre côté.
Beaucoup disent que les hommes
se transforment en anges,
nous n'en savons rien.
Les théologiens
s'appuyant sur les Écritures
disent que nous ne
pouvons pas devenir des anges.
Les hommes ne deviennent pas des anges
et les anges ne deviennent pas des hommes,
car les anges appartiennent
à la hiérarchie de Dieu.
Ils sont surnaturels, ils ne sont pas un
prolongement de la condition humaine.
Ils ont été créés par Dieu
dans l'intérêt de la condition humaine.
Pour essayer de créer un
ordre dans le monde des anges,
les théologiens du Moyen Âge créèrent
le concept des neuf chœurs d'anges
ordonnés en cercles
concentriques autour du trône de Dieu.
Vous avez au centre les Séraphins
incorruptibles dont l'essence est l'amour,
les chérubins
dont l'essence est le savoir.
Puis des couches successives
jusqu'aux troupes de choc
qui se trouvent à la
périphérie, près du mal,
et des hommes qui sont
les pécheurs de ce monde cosmique.
Les archanges et des anges.
On pensait que les anges
surveillaient les rouages de l'univers.
Il y avait des anges pour tout,
les saisons, les planètes,
la poésie, l'insomnie.
Cette idée fut largement
acceptée jusqu'au XIVème siècle,
lorsque des événements vinrent porter
atteinte à la crédibilité des anges.
D'abord la peste noire qui décima près
de la moitié de la population européenne
alors que celle-ci voyait
les anges comme ses protecteurs.
Après que la peste eut
complètement décimé l'Europe
et que ses habitants
eurent commencé à se remettre,
ils se fichèrent
complètement des anges,
qui s'étaient révélés
parfaitement inutiles.
L'épreuve suivante ne tarda pas à arriver.
À la Renaissance,
des scientifiques comme Copernic,
découvrirent la vraie
nature du système solaire
et l'idée que les anges animaient
les astres et les planètes, sembla naïve.
Le doute donc est apparu et persiste.
Parce que plus nous en apprenons
sur ce que nous pensions être régies
par une puissance mystérieuse ou divine,
plus nous pouvons expliquer
ces choses de façon scientifique,
plus nous avons
du mal à croire aux anges.
En dépit de ces diverses
épreuves, les anges tinrent bon
et continuèrent d'apparaître sur terre
et souvent à des personnages historiques.
Jeanne d'Arc se battit
avec héroïsme pour la France
parce que l'ange
Saint-Michel le lui avait ordonné,
même si cela a servi de prétexte
à ses ennemis pour la brûler vives.
Les anges étaient aussi là
lorsque l'Amérique devint une nation.
La légende veut que
George Washington ait vu un ange,
un ange féminin qui lui est apparu
et lui a montré l'histoire des États-Unis.
Les anges faisaient partie de la foi
et des croyances de Washington.
Au cours de la Première Guerre mondiale,
des anges se manifestèrent
sur les champs de bataille européens.
Selon des récits publiés à l'époque,
des soldats britanniques
qui se battaient à Mons en Belgique,
à la fin août 1914, ont vu
apparaître dans le ciel des anges
qui les ont défendues contre
les Allemands, contre l'ennemi.
D'autres récits venant
des bataillons allemands
mentionnent des cavaliers spectraux.
Des chevaliers sur leurs montures et des
êtres lumineux armés d'arcs, de flèches
et d'épées qui se battaient dans le
ciel au-dessus des soldats britanniques,
contrecarrant l'offensive allemande
et protégeant les soldats britanniques.
Que ce soit sur les champs de bataille
ou dans les idées plus romantiques
de la Renaissance
et sous de multiples formes,
les anges ont toujours
été nos compagnons fidèles.
Aujourd'hui, notre planète
traverse de profonds bouleversements,
nous sommes nombreux à espérer
que les anges de lumière
veillent toujours sur nous.
Plus la science a expliqué notre univers,
plus le rôle des anges
dans notre vie a diminué.
Pourtant, malgré toutes les découvertes,
ils continuent de nous
fasciner plus que jamais.
Les anges gardiens peuvent
apparaître de différentes façons.
Ils peuvent revêtir la forme d'un rêve,
d'un sentiment et parfois même d'une voix.
Ils peuvent nous guider
ou nous sauver la vie,
mais seulement
si nous les écoutons.
Les anges viennent, ils n'aiment
pas être vus, ils veulent se déguiser.
Ils ne vont pas faire irruption
et bouleverser notre réalité.
Ils vont donc nous apparaître comme
des visions, des voix, une intuition.
Une tape sur l'épaule qui
vous dit, va par là, pas là-bas.
Cette intuition, c'est la voix d'un
ange qui vous chuchote des conseils.
La chanteuse Becky Hobbs
insuffle du courage à son public,
mais la voix qui lui a sauvé la vie
en 1986 était celle de son ange gardien.
J'ai commencé à avoir des prémonitions
quelques semaines avant Noël.
J'allais avoir un
grave accident de la route.
Ces prémonitions me venaient
dès que je commençais à m'endormir.
Tout à coup,
j'étais prise dans l'accident.
Je me redressais dans mon lit,
mon cœur battait la chamade
et je me sentais complètement désespérée.
Les messages continuent jusqu'à
la veille de son 29ème anniversaire.
Mon anniversaire était le 24 janvier.
J'ai passé la nuit
à faire des gâteaux pour ma fête.
J'étais dans la cuisine et j'ai senti
quelqu'un me tirer par la manche.
Quelque chose
m'a entraînée dans le jardin.
J'ai regardé le ciel et j'ai dit,
qu'essayez-vous de me dire ?
Qu'est-ce que je dois faire ?
Cette voix m'a répondu, sois prudente,
cela pourrait bien être
ton dernier anniversaire.
Le jour suivant, le 25 janvier,
je suis montée dans ma camionnette
avec mon groupe et on
est allé à Albertville, en Alabama.
On y a donné un concert
le soir au profit de la police.
Après le concert, on rentrait à l'hôtel.
Il y avait du brouillard
comme il y en a la nuit en janvier.
C'est un trajet banal
jusqu'à ce que Becky entende
la voix qu'elle a entendue la veille.
Tout à coup, son effrayant
message devient clair.
Becky comprend que le camion qui
approche ne va pas respecter le feu rouge.
Tout à coup, je me suis dit,
c'est ce qu'ils ont essayé de me
dire hier soir et l'angoisse m'a envahi.
Le feu est passé au vert
et Becky hurlait, Runsh, attention !
On a été touché à l'avant gauche du
véhicule, autrement dit une partie solide.
Une seconde plus tard,
on aurait été touché sur le côté.
La police nous a dit
qu'on avait eu de la chance,
une seconde plus tard,
on aurait tous été tués.
La voix et son message prémonitoire
avaient sauvé la vie
de Becky et de ses amis.
J'ai toujours cru qu'on voyait des anges,
c'est faux, on peut aussi les entendre.
La voix était celle de mon ange
gardien, c'est aussi simple que cela.
Les anges sont faits de lumière
et ils peuvent prendre
toutes les formes qu'ils veulent.
Ils peuvent être homme
ou femme, grands ou petits.
Ils peuvent être des
enfants ou gigantesques
et quand ils viennent,
ils vous transforment.
C'est un moment d'une puissance inouïe
que vous porterez en vous
jusqu'à la fin de vos jours.
Eileen Freeman, auteur de
best-seller écrit sur les anges,
parce qu'ils ont
profondément changé sa vie.
J'étais à l'université
de Wagner à New York.
Un jour, je suis allée rendre visite
à un ami à quelques blocs de chez moi.
En chemin, Eileen
a un étrange pressentiment.
J'ai pensé comme cela doit arriver
à tous ceux qui vivent à New York
que quelqu'un allait
me faire du mal, être agressée.
Au moment où elle arrive chez son ami,
quelque chose d'étrange se produit.
J'ai senti une main
sur mon épaule me retenir.
Je me suis retournée rapidement,
mais il n'y avait personne.
Je me suis dit que j'avais dû
rêver ou une contraction musculaire.
Il y avait quelques marches
jusqu'à la porte d'entrée.
Au moment où j'ai posé le pied droit sur
l'escalier, j'ai senti de nouveau la main.
Elle m'a tirée plus fort cette fois-ci
et m'a littéralement tirée en arrière.
En même temps,
j'ai entendu une voix me dire
que ce serait imprudent
d'entrer maintenant.
Cela s'est passé vite,
juste une phrase,
ce ne serait pas prudent
d'entrer maintenant.
En l'entendant, j'ai eu un tremblement
que je ne pourrais pas définir.
Effrayée, Eileen traverse
la rue et se réfugie dans une église.
Elle s'assoit pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui vient de se passer.
C'est alors qu'un
souvenir étonnant lui revient.
Je ne sais pas comment,
mais j'ai compris que c'était
la voix de mon ange gardien.
Eileen s'est souvenue
combien la mort de sa grand-mère
l'avait éprouvée
quand elle avait cinq ans.
Eileen avait peur que
sa grand-mère l'aime tellement
qu'elle revienne
et l'emmène avec elle.
Elle avait si peur
qu'elle n'arrivait plus à dormir.
Dans l'obscurité, une nuit,
Eileen avait vu une lumière
inquiétante apparaître au pied de son lit.
J'ai cru que c'était la lumière
du couloir, mais elle n'était pas allumée.
J'ai regardé cette lumière
et j'ai vu une forme humaine en sortir.
Je me souviens surtout de ses
yeux parce qu'ils étaient perçants
et malgré tout pleins de compassion.
Cette forme m'a dit,
n'aie pas peur, Eileen,
ta grand-mère est heureuse
au ciel avec les gens qu'elle aime.
J'ai dit, qui êtes-vous ?
Il a répondu, je suis
ton ange gardien, mon enfant.
N'oublie jamais,
il n'y a pas de quoi avoir peur
et la peur m'a quittée
pendant qu'il me parlait.
Lorsqu'Eileen émerge de son souvenir,
elle entend des sirènes à l'extérieur.
Elle ramasse ses affaires
et se précipite hors de l'église.
Dans la rue, Eileen est ébahie de
voir devant l'immeuble de son ami
des voitures de police et des ambulances.
J'ai commencé à traverser la rue,
mais un policier m'a arrêté
et m'a dit que je ne pouvais pas entrer.
Eileen apprendra plus tard
que quelques instants après que
l'ange l'ait détourné de son chemin,
une femme a été assassinée
dans l'ascenseur de l'immeuble.
J'ai compris ce que mon ange avait
voulu me dire que ce ne serait pas prudent
d'entrer maintenant,
je ne l'avais pas vu.
En fait, je ne l'ai jamais revu
comme je l'avais vu quand j'étais enfant,
mais je sais que c'était sa voix.
C'est là que j'ai compris
qu'il m'avait sauvé la vie.
Parfois, le travail d'un
ange gardien est très subtil.
Il peut simplement nous donner
le courage et la force de continuer.
En 1991, un marine américain,
Tim Altizer, est mobilisé
pour l'opération Tempête du désert.
Son bataillon se déplace
avec des véhicules amphibies
des Amtrak au milieu
de puits de pétrole en feu.
Il y avait des flammes partout.
Tous les 40 mètres, c'était un vrai
brasier, les flammes étaient immenses.
On sentait la chaleur autour de nous.
On ne pouvait pas dire
si c'était le jour ou la nuit.
On était tous
épuisé et on avait peur.
On se demandait
si notre Amtrak n'allait pas sauter.
La religion, ce n'était pas fait
pour moi, mais on s'est y tous tournés
quand on a été envoyé
dans la guerre du Golfe.
Si tu étais déjà croyant,
tu le devenais encore plus.
Si tu ne l'étais pas, tu le devenais
parce qu'on avait tous très peur.
La terreur grandit
lorsqu'ils apprennent par radio
que leur Amtrak se dirige
vers des mines antichars.
Tim sait qu'il peut mourir
d'un moment à l'autre.
Entre les balles qui passaient pas loin
de l'Amtrak et les mines terrestres.
On savait qu'on était séparé du
carburant par de simples parois
et qu'on serait dans un cercueil en feu
s'il arrivait quelque chose à l'Amtrak.
J'étais assis tout au fond
à gauche, dans un petit recoin,
avec tout mon matériel autour de moi.
J'ai regardé à ma gauche
et j'ai vu quelque chose.
Je ne savais pas ce que c'était.
Une sorte de forme
humaine qui me regardait.
J'ai eu peur, car personne
ne pouvait être assis à cet endroit.
Je l'ai regardé, il m'a regardé
et il m'a dit de ne pas m'inquiéter
et que tout allait bien se passer.
J'ai compris que c'était un ange.
Après cela, je me suis tourné vers mon
copain et je lui ai dit, tu as vu cela ?
Il a eu l'air surpris,
il ne voyait pas de quoi je parlais.
Je me suis retourné
et il n'y avait plus rien.
Bientôt, Amtrak sort du champ de mines.
Le message de l'ange est devenu réalité.
Cela ne ressemblait pas du tout
à l'image que je me faisais des anges.
Avec des ailes,
une auréole et tout cela,
mais j'ai eu une impression de douceur.
Moi-même, je me sentais comme
dans du coton, bizarrement.
Tout était moelleux comme de la
guimauve, comme si j'étais dans du coton.
Deux ou trois heures après la visite
de mon ange, la guerre était terminée.
Je pense que je suis protégé,
Je pense que quelqu'un veille sur moi.
Cela ne fait aucun doute
pour moi, c'était un ange.
De nombreux grands artistes
ont été inspirés par des anges.
Quelques-uns des plus
grands chefs-d'œuvre du monde
reflètent leur beauté et leur mystère.
C'est vrai aujourd'hui
que cela l'a été il y a mille ans.
Nous avons rencontré un homme
qui est inspiré par des anges,
a créé le chef-d'œuvre de sa vie.
Je ne crois pas avoir été un élu.
Je pense que les anges
choisissent certaines personnes
lorsqu'elles traversent une période de
désespoir, mon heure n'était pas venue.
L'artiste Andy Lakey
avait vécu dangereusement
jusqu'au jour
où des anges sont venus le sauver.
Avant ma rencontre avec
les anges, j'étais représentant.
Je me droguais et je savais
que j'allais avoir des ennuis.
Parce que la drogue passait avant
mes factures et cela me faisait peur.
Andy avoue que la drogue qu'il
prenait depuis des années le détruisait.
Jusqu'à ce qu'un soir
de 1986, il appelle au secours.
Au cours de cette fête chez
un copain, j'ai eu une sensation étrange.
J'ai eu très peur,
j'avais l'impression que mon corps
allait s'arrêter de
fonctionner, j'étais mort de peur.
J'ai réussi à rentrer chez moi.
Je me souviens avoir
rampé jusqu'à la douche.
J'ai réussi à me mettre
dessous et j'ai ouvert l'eau froide.
J'étais encore habillé,
je sentais mon corps s'éteindre.
Alors je me suis mis à prier et j'ai
dit à Dieu que s'il me laissait vivre,
je ne toucherais plus jamais à la drogue,
et je ferais aussi
quelque chose pour l'humanité.
Presque immédiatement, j'ai senti
quelque chose tournoyer à mes pieds.
J'ai commencé à voir des anges,
cette sensation m'a envahi.
Les anges sont venus vers moi, ont mis
leurs bras autour de moi et m'ont protégé.
Je n'hallucinais pas, j'avais
l'impression que mon corps mourait.
Au fur et à mesure que les
anges enveloppaient mes pieds,
ma poitrine, j'étais envahi
par un sentiment de paix.
Après sa rencontre avec les anges,
l'un des amis d'Andy le retrouve glacé
sous la douche et l'emmène à l'hôpital.
Le médecin m'a dit
que j'aurais pu mourir,
qu'il y avait assez de cocaïne
dans mon organisme pour me tuer.
Andy a-t-il vraiment vu des anges
ou a-t-il été victime d'une
hallucination causée par la drogue ?
C'était davantage qu'une hallucination,
beaucoup de gens se droguent,
voient des anges et vivent ce genre
d'expérience, mais ils ne s'arrêtent pas.
Andy a connu une expérience de mort
proche, il est passé très près de la mort.
Les anges sont apparus
et lui ont fait une telle impression
que toute sa vie a changée.
Andy pense que les anges
lui ont donné une deuxième chance.
Il a arrêté la drogue du jour au lendemain
et s'est mis à dessiner des anges.
Après le travail, je rentrais
à la maison et au lieu de me droguer,
je dessinais des anges.
Parfois des heures durant,
en essayant de reproduire avec exactitude
ce que j'avais ressenti
et vu sous la douche.
Andy pense qu'une force angélique
le pousse à peindre ses anges sur toile,
mais il ne savait pas
peindre jusqu'en 1989,
quand les anges sont
encore venus lui rendre visite.
Une petite boule de lumière est
venue vers moi et m'a touché au front.
Elle scintillait et j'ai
communiqué avec trois anges
qui m'ont donné des tas d'informations
et qui m'ont notamment appris mon art.
C'est comme cela que j'ai commencé
à peindre le lendemain même.
Avant de disparaître dans
les nuages, les trois anges
annoncent à Andy qu'ils lui
rendront de nouveau visite en l'an 2000.
D'ici là, il devra avoir peint 2 000 anges
représentant chaque année
depuis la naissance du Christ.
Ce qu'ils m'ont dit, même
si ce n'était pas avec des mots,
c'est de peindre
et nous nous occupons du reste.
Tu as une mission à remplir.
Andy ne sait pas quelle est sa mission,
mais il quitte son travail
et comme par miracle,
il se met à peindre sur toile
des anges en trois dimensions.
Ce sont les anges qui
m'ont transmis l'art de peindre.
J'ai compris comment utiliser la peinture
grâce à cette rencontre avec les anges
et pour que celle-ci soit éternelle.
Les critiques d'art et la presse finissent
par entendre parler des tableaux d'Andy,
dont on dit qu'ils renferment des symboles
et des messages secrets
sur des surfaces rendues durables.
J'ai dit à Andy que ses tableaux étaient
très intéressants, puis-je les toucher ?
Puis je l'ai regardé et je lui ai dit
qu'il devrait peindre pour les aveugles
et pas seulement pour les voyants,
car on peut comprendre le message
de vos tableaux aussi par le toucher.
C'est à ce moment-là qu'Andy comprend
ce que les anges attendent de lui.
Il y a eu un déclic,
ma mission était d'arrêter la drogue
et de faire quelque chose pour l'humanité.
Alors, je me suis dit que j'allais faire
don de mes tableaux pour les enfants.
Depuis, des centaines de bienfaiteurs
ont acheté des tableaux
d'Andy au profit des aveugles.
Stevie Wonder et Ray Charles
font partie des donateurs.
La première personne
qui a répondu, c'est le pape
et il m'a dit qu'il serait honoré
d'avoir un de mes anges au Vatican.
Andy pense que les anges lui ont offert
la vie alors en retour, il offre son art.
Avant, la seule façon pour
un non-voyant d'apprécier l'art,
c'était de toucher les sculptures.
Je viens de terminer
des tableaux d'animaux.
Être avec ces petits enfants aveugles,
être témoin de l'amour des parents,
de celui des enfants et voir
qu'en plus ils aiment mes tableaux.
Cela a donné une
autre dimension à ma vie.
En plus de ces animaux, Andy est bien
décidé à finir ses 2 000 tableaux d'anges
avant sa prochaine
rencontre avec les anges.
Je sais que ce sera en l'an 2000.
Je dois attendre jusqu'en 1999,
quand j'aurai fini mes 2 000 tableaux,
on saura le 31 décembre 1999.
À minuit, je mettrais la dernière
touche à mon dernier ange, le 2 000ème.
Andy a déjà peint 700 anges et espère
transmettre son secret à d'autres.
Les anges semblent visiter des gens
de tous âges et de tous horizons.
Certains sont plus disposés
que d'autres à les accepter.
Il y a ceux qui les accueillent sans
hésitation, ils sont purs et innocents.
Il s'agit des enfants,
mais même ces experts-là
ont des perceptions différentes.
Un ange, c'est quelqu'un qui vole.
Les anges existent
dans toutes les couleurs.
On peut les toucher,
mais on passe à travers.
Il y en a des noirs et des blancs.
Ils sont censés être beaux,
parfaits et pleins de couleurs.
Il y en a des rouges.
- Ils sont comme l'air et la lumière.
Si on leur donne un coup
de pied, ils seront furieux,
mais cela ne leur fera pas mal.
On ne peut pas voir les anges,
mais on sait qu'ils sont là.
Ils aident les nouveaux anges, les anges
qui viennent de sortir des morts.
Les anges sont des
esprits qui vous aident.
C'est comme quand on
fait visiter l'école à un nouveau.
Ils ne viennent pas sur terre,
sauf s'ils sont en mission.
Ils vous aident à réfléchir,
à faire ce qu'il faut.
Si vous êtes blessé
ou si vous allez mourir,
un ange viendra peut-être vous aider.
Chez la plupart des enfants,
ces créatures capricieuses
ne font que nourrir une imagination
débordante, mais chez d'autres,
ce sont des messagers qui ont
la réponse à des questions très adultes.
Mallory Shrieves
souffrait d'un cancer incurable.
Elle n'avait que neuf ans
et avait peur de mourir.
Après, presque un an d'un
traitement qui avait ravagé son corps
et laissé intact le cancer,
trois anges lui sont apparus en rêve.
Ils venaient la réconforter,
l'aider à comprendre, l'aider à mourir.
Elle est entrée à l'hôpital
pour subir une chimiothérapie.
La nuit précédente,
elle a fait son premier rêve
et elle a dit qu'elle avait rêvé
de trois anges qui étaient venus la voir.
Elle nous a dit qu'ils l'avaient
emmenée en voyage pour visiter le ciel.
Quand elle m'a raconté cela,
je me suis demandé si c'était vrai.
En l'écoutant,
j'ai compris que c'était vrai.
Je dormais et ils venaient me voir.
Ils ne me montraient pas leur visage,
mais ils étaient si beaux.
La première fois, ils se sont
juste assis et ils m'ont parlé.
Lorsqu'elle m'en parlait,
c'était tant réel
pour moi, cela la passionnait.
Elle avait plus d'énergie
que je ne lui en avais jamais connu.
J'étais aussi passionnée car
je me disais que c'est formidable
qu'elle puisse voir les anges.
Il y avait un ange blanc,
il portait une robe blanche.
Ses ailes étaient si belles
et on pouvait arracher une plume,
puis une autre, et encore une autre.
Elles repoussaient comme
si on ne les avait pas touchées.
Elles étaient magiques,
mais c'était vraiment très bien.
Parce que maman m'a
dit que quand je partirai,
je n'aurai pas besoin
de m'inquiéter pour mes ailes.
Elles pousseraient toutes seules.
Je trouvais cela effrayant au début,
mais ce n'est pas effrayant.
Elle m'a raconté qu'ils l'avaient
emmenée et posée sur un nuage.
Ils lui avaient dit
de ne pas avoir peur,
qu'ils l'aimaient et qu'elle
ne serait pas malade au ciel.
Qu'elle pourrait vivre
éternellement là-bas
et que tout ce qu'elle aimait ici,
elle le retrouverait là-bas.
Ils m'ont aspergé
et j'ai commencé à flotter avec eux.
On pouvait aller où on voulait.
Les anges me disaient que
je pouvais aller là ou alors là-bas,
où je voulais et que
c'était moi qui choisissais.
Mallory disait qu'elle n'était plus malade
quand elle était en présence d'ange
Elle pouvait faire ce qu'elle voulait.
Un soir, elle leur a dit
qu'elle voulait danser
et elle nous a raconté
qu'elle avait dansé, dansé, dansé.
Ils l'ont emmenée dans les nuages et
je lui ai demandé que c'était comment ?
Elle m'a dit que c'était merveilleux,
doux et qu'ils avaient tous les goûts.
Ils me laissaient
essayer les nuages, les goûters.
Ils avaient
le goût de ce que je voulais.
Par exemple, si je voulais
de la banane, je disais,
je voudrais que cela
ait le goût de la banane.
Ils me disaient c'est ce que tu veux,
je leur disais que oui,
je goûtais et cela
avait le goût de la banane.
Si je voulais le goût d'une glace,
je l'avais et je pouvais avoir
tous les mélanges que
je voulais, c'était très bien.
Elle parlait d'un royaume de fées
où elle pouvait faire du coloriage,
courir, danser et être la petite
fille qu'elle était avant sa maladie.
C'est ce qui la rendait vraiment heureuse.
Cela lui a prouvé
qu'autre chose l'attendait,
qu'il n'y avait pas que la mort.
Il n'a jamais été nécessaire que Mallory
prenne des médicaments antidouleur.
Elle a donc toujours
été parfaitement consciente.
Elle n'a eu que des rêves peuplés d'ange,
des rêves qui l'ont aidée à mourir,
des rêves qu'elle voulait partager.
Elle a tenu à nous apporter son
témoignage pour offrir du réconfort
à d'autres enfants
et les aider à accepter la mort.
J'aimerais partir la nuit pour que cela ne
me fasse pas mal, pendant que je dors.
Si je pars dans la journée,
j'aimerais dire au revoir à ma maman,
à mes frères, à mes sœurs
et à papa avant de partir.
Lorsque l'état de santé
de Mallory s'est aggravé,
les choses ont commencé à changer.
Le soir de la Saint-Valentin,
j'ai cru qu'elle allait nous quitter.
J'avais très peur,
c'était le jour préféré de Mallory.
Elle était dans son lit,
elle dormait et tout à coup,
je l'ai entendue m'appeler.
Je suis allée dans sa chambre
et elle m'a dit qu'un
un ange était venu la voir.
Je lui ai dit, un ange, un seul ?
Elle a dit, oui.
Jusque-là, il avait toujours été trois.
Je lui ai demandé
à quoi il ressemblait ?
et elle m'a répondu qu'il
était plus beau que les autres.
Je lui ai dit, est-ce que
son nom était Annabelle ?
C'est le nom de ma grand-mère.
En écarquillant les yeux
et elle m'a dit, comment tu le sais ?
Le 19 février 1994, cinq jours
après la visite d'Annabelle, l'ange,
Mallory est entrée dans le coma,
elle s'est éteinte 24 heures plus tard.
Je pense que les anges
voulaient qu'elle dise aux gens
qu'il y a quelque chose
de l'autre côté après la mort,
qu'il y a une vie
entière qui ne finit pas.
Croyez ce que je vous dis
parce que c'est vrai.
Vraiment.
Un sondage Gallup de 1981 fait apparaître
que plus de 20 millions
de gens ont frôlé la mort.
Huit millions d'entre eux affirment
avoir eu une expérience de mort proche
au cours de laquelle ils ont
baigné dans une lumière spirituelle
avant d'être ramenés à la vie.
La plupart déclarent aussi
avoir rencontré des anges de l'autre côté.
Bizarrement, ceux qui ont survécu
à ces expériences de mort proche
font des récits étonnamment similaires
du voyage qui a suivi leur mort clinique.
Ils racontent avoir vu leur
corps par-dessus les médecins
qui tentaient
l'impossible pour les sauver.
Puis, dans l'obscurité qui a suivi,
ils ont traversé un long tunnel au
bout duquel brillait une lumière vive.
Ils ont entendu
une musique merveilleuse,
le bruit du vent et ils ont
goûté une paix profonde.
Le docteur Raymond Moody,
considéré comme le spécialiste
du phénomène de
l'expérience de mort proche
depuis la parution de son livre,
La vie après la vie en 1970.
Nous parle d'une
autre similitude frappante.
Très souvent, lors de ces expériences, ils
rencontrent un être divin ou angélique.
Cet être peut leur donner un choix.
Vous pouvez retourner
vers la vie que vous meniez
ou vous pouvez
poursuivre cette expérience.
Il est intéressant de
constater qu'ils disent tous
que si cela n'avait tenu
qu'à eux, ils seraient restés.
Ils auraient préféré rester avec
cette lumière et cet amour formidable,
mais ils ont choisi de
revenir parce qu'en général,
ils avaient de jeunes enfants à élever.
C'est le cas de Robert Turner,
architecte et marathonien,
qui a rencontré son ange gardien
après être entré au service des urgences
d'un hôpital du Massachusetts où les
médecins n'ont pu que constater son décès.
C'était par une journée de grande chaleur,
le 20 juillet 1970
à deux heures de l'après-midi.
Je crois qu'il faisait près de 37 degrés.
La course avait commencé à 14 h 15.
J'ai couru les deux
premiers kilomètres très, très vite.
Je savais que cela n'allait pas,
j'avais la bouche complètement sèche,
je ne transpirais plus.
Assez vite, tous les autres coureurs
ont disparu et puis je n'ai plus rien vu.
J'ai continué la course,
pratiquement inconscient.
Robert s'écroule sur la ligne d'arrivée,
au pied de sa femme
et de ses deux jeunes enfants.
Il est transporté jusqu'à une voiture
et emmené à l'hôpital le plus proche.
Malgré les tentatives de réanimation
d'un policier, Robert n'a plus de pouls.
Je savais qu'il était mort.
Je les ai entendus dire
que son cœur ne battait plus
et quand il est arrivé
aux urgences, il ne respirait plus.
J'ai regardé le moniteur
cardiaque et j'ai vu qu'il était plat.
Je savais que mon cœur s'était arrêté de
battre et que j'allais sans doute mourir.
J'ai ressenti une unité que
je n'avais jamais ressentie jusque-là.
Je faisais partie des gens dans
la pièce, mais aussi de l'univers entier.
Je suis parti pour ce voyage merveilleux
avec mon ange qui sera toujours avec moi
et marchera toujours à ma gauche.
J'ai su qu'il s'appelait Joseph.
Pendant que son corps
est dans le coma à l'hôpital,
son esprit parcourt une forêt merveilleuse
baignée d'une étonnante lumière.
C'est là qu'il rencontre son ange gardien.
Il m'a dit de rester où j'étais
et il s'est avancé vers ce groupe
et ils ont commencé à parler.
Ils m'ont tous regardé,
je savais qu'il parlait de moi.
Puis mon ange Joseph est revenu vers moi
et il m'a dit que j'avais une mission,
que mon heure n'était pas venue,
qu'il devait me ramener.
Dix-sept heures plus tard,
Robert sort de son coma.
C'est après des années
qu'il va avoir le courage
de parler à sa femme
de son voyage extraordinaire
et de lui dire combien
il a été changé par son expérience.
Il prend le temps de vivre.
Autrefois, son métier
l'accaparait et aujourd'hui,
on s'arrête pour sentir les roses,
ce qu'on ne faisait jamais avant.
Le docteur Melvin Morse,
pédiatre et auteur du best-seller,
Closer to the Light,
plus près de la lumière,
fait autorité dans le domaine des enfants
et des expériences de mort proche.
Au fil des années,
il a rassemblé des centaines de récits
et de dessins d'enfants
décrivant leur rencontre avec des anges.
L'une des histoires les plus étonnantes
est celle de Jamie Huntinen
qui, à l'âge de cinq ans,
est admise au service des urgences
alors que son cœur a cessé de battre.
Jamie passée aussi près
de la mort que l'on peut aller.
Tout en ayant encore
une chance d'être réanimée
avec la technologie d'aujourd'hui.
Dix minutes de plus et elle mourait.
Elle a été amenée dans
notre service de traumatologie.
On l'a tout de suite mise sous perfusion
et placée sous oxygène.
Puis son cœur s'est arrêté et on lui a
fait une réanimation cardio-pulmonaire,
elle était cliniquement morte.
Alors qu'elle est allongée sur la table,
Jamie flotte hors de
son corps et se voit étendue.
Je suis allée au ciel,
j'ai vu Dieu et des anges.
Dieu m'a parlé, il m'a dit que
mon heure n'était pas venue de mourir.
Il m'a annoncé
que ma mère allait avoir un bébé,
que je devais repartir
et aider ma mère avec mon petit frère.
Puis je suis rentrée
de nouveau dans mon corps,
je me suis réveillée
et j'étais en soins intensifs.
Je lui ai demandé si elle pouvait
dessiner ce qu'elle venait de vivre.
Elle a fait un dessin saisissant,
on la voit sur un lit.
Tous les détails de
sa réanimation sont exacts.
Ce sont des détails
qu'elle ne peut pas avoir inventés
ou pêchés en regardant la télé.
Là, c'est quand ils essayent de
me réanimer et là, c'est quand je flotte.
Cela, c'est Dieu et les trois anges.
Cela lui a apporté une confirmation.
Maintenant, elle sait
que ce qui lui est arrivé était réel.
Elle partage avec d'autres
enfants qui sont gravement malades
ou qui vont mourir du cancer
ou de maladies incurables.
Elle les rassure sur la mort.
Un grand nombre de ceux qui
ont connu une mort temporaire
disent que leurs anges gardiens
leur ont donné le choix
de venir avec eux ou non.
C'est le cas de Ron Kennedy,
un médecin de San Francisco
qui a survécu après avoir été
sauvagement poignardé plus de 13 fois.
Un jour qu'il rentre
d'une conférence à l'étranger,
il découvre l'ami qui garde
sa maison assis dans l'escalier,
en pleine crise de démence.
J'ai vu mon ami Abdoul
assis dans l'escalier.
Je lui avais demandé de garder
la maison pendant mon absence.
J'ai vu des perles de sueur
sur son front et je lui ai dit, ça va ?
Il s'est mis à hurler à pleins poumons.
Je n'avais pas vu qu'il tenait un
raquette de tennis dans la main droite.
Ensuite, je ne me souviens de rien
jusqu'au moment où je suis revenu à moi.
Là, j'ai vu qu'il brandissait un poignard
et j'ai compris que
je n'avais aucune chance,
qu'il avait le dessus
et que j'allais mourir.
J'ai vu derrière lui une sorte de couloir.
Il n'y a pas de couloir
chez moi à cet endroit.
Là, le temps s'est arrêté.
Dans ce couloir, une lumière est apparue
qui a commencé à prendre une forme humaine
et m'a posé une question.
Plutôt, elle m'a lancé cette question
un peu comme une flèche dans la poitrine.
Ce n'était pas des mots,
c'était l'essence de la pensée même.
La question était celle-ci,
veux-tu venir maintenant ou plus tard ?
Je voulais savoir
ce qu'il y avait de l'autre côté,
mais je voyais qu'il y avait des choses
dans ma vie qui n'étaient pas terminées.
Mon fils avait trois ans,
j'étais imprégné de son esprit,
de sa présence
et c'est ce qui a fait la différence.
J'ai dit sûrement pas, je ne viens
pas maintenant, je n'ai pas terminé.
J'ai répondu à la question
de façon aussi directe
qu'elle m'avait été
posée et je suis resté.
Il a fallu dix ans avant que Ron Kennedy
arrive à parler de son expérience
et à comprendre ce
qu'il avait vu et éprouvé.
Après cela, je me suis dit que
l'amour qui avait jailli de cette lumière
était si grand que
cela signifiait sans doute
qu'il fallait apprendre
à aimer comme cela.
Apprendre à aimer comme
cela ou peut-être mieux encore,
apprendre à être aimé comme cela.
Vivre l'amour que les
gens éprouvent pour nous.
L'histoire de Ron
sert à aider les familles
des victimes d'assassinat
qui craignent que leurs êtres chers
soient morts seuls
et dans la souffrance.
Cette lumière m'est apparue
dans ces circonstances-là.
On était en train de
m'assassiner et malgré tout,
je n'allais pas
mourir seul, c'était clair.
J'allais mourir dans
un immense océan d'amour.
Si j'avais quelque chose à dire aux gens,
je leur dirais, les êtres
que vous aimez et qui sont morts
dans des circonstances épouvantables.
Si mon expérience est significative,
cela veut dire qu'ils ne sont pas
morts seuls comme vous le craigniez,
ils sont morts entourés d'amour.
Il arrive souvent
que la médecine d'aujourd'hui
ne puisse expliquer
une guérison spontanée.
Beaucoup pensent que les anges
rendent visite aux malades et aux mourants
pour sauver une vie
ou faire un miracle.
En janvier 1981, les médecins ont
annoncé à mon mari, Chris Mears,
qu'il souffrait d'une leucémie aiguë.
Chris venait de subir plusieurs
séances de chimiothérapie
les ayant complètement épuisé.
Il ne pouvait plus marcher
tout seul, il ne mangeait plus.
Il dormait 24 h sur 24 si on ne
venait pas le réveiller et le lever.
Il était clair qu'il était
en train de perdre la bataille.
Melissa dort toujours sur un lit
d'appoint à quelques centimètres de Chris.
Le 4 janvier, à trois heures du matin,
elle est réveillée par
une infirmière, Chris a disparu.
J'ai paniqué,
je n'y comprenais plus rien.
Il ne peut pas marcher,
comment s'est-il levé ?
Comment est-il passé devant
mon lit sans que je m'en aperçoive ?
Où est-il ?
Que se passe-t-il ?
C'est alors que Melissa remarque une lueur
derrière une porte au bout du couloir.
Elle ouvre la porte et découvre
Chris et dans un coin de la pièce
se trouve un personnage étrange.
Sa peau était si blanche,
elle était presque transparente.
Je n'en revenais pas de la couleur de
ses yeux, ils étaient d'un bleu si clair.
Il avait l'air d'un adolescent, mais
il émanait de lui une telle sagesse.
J'ai vu qu'il portait une chemise
de flanelle, des jeans et des bottes.
Chris était musicien
et il s'habillait souvent comme cela.
Je pense qu'il s'était habillé comme
cela pour que Chris se sente à l'aise.
Melissa comprend que Chris
veut rester seul quelques instants
et va dans sa chambre.
Quelques minutes
plus tard, Chris la rejoint.
Elle lui demande qui était l'étranger.
Je n'oublierai jamais son visage.
Il avait l'air de me dire, tu ne vas
pas croire ce que je vais te dire.
Il m'a dit que c'était un ange gardien.
Après la visite de l'ange,
Chris s'est rajeuni.
Il est en meilleure santé et plus
heureux qu'il ne l'a été depuis des mois.
Il souriait, il mangeait, il rendait
visite aux malades des autres chambres.
Il avait une énergie incroyable.
Il était complètement changé.
Quand il s'était couché,
c'était un homme qui portait
le fardeau d'une maladie incurable.
Quand il est revenu dans sa chambre,
c'était le jeune homme en
bonne santé que j'avais épousé.
C'était différent, il avait changé.
Les deux jours
suivants sont pleins de joie,
mais le troisième, Chris perd son combat.
Il s'éteint paisiblement
avec Mélissa à ses côtés.
L'ange n'était pas venu soigner son corps.
La plupart des gens pensent
que lorsqu'ils voient un ange,
cela veut dire que s'ils sont
malades, ils vont être guéris.
Là, c'était un miracle d'un autre genre.
Je pense que bien que le corps,
bien que l'enveloppe corporelle de Chris
n'ait pas survécu,
son esprit a été soigné.
Quel que soit le voyage ou l'aventure
dans laquelle il s'est embarqué,
je pense que lorsqu'il est parti,
il était fort et il était prêt.
Tôt ou tard, chacun d'entre nous
se posera des questions sur la mort.
Que nous arrivera-t-il quand
nous passerons de vie à trépas ?
La seule chose que nous puissions espérer,
c'est que lorsque notre heure sera venue,
un ange sera là pour nous
épauler et nous accompagner.
Certains pensent que
nous vivons dans un monde
où se côtoient le bien et le mal
et que chacun a son ange.
Les anges déchus représentent le mal.
Beaucoup pensent que
sans lui, le bien n'existerait pas.
Il y a des anges des ténèbres, des démons
et il y a une foule d'anges
qui suggèrent le mal, la peur.
Cela peut être l'ange du cancer,
celui de l'ignorance, celui de l'échec.
Je pense que les anges
apportent ces choses-là aussi.
Une maladie ou un échec
peuvent avoir leur place dans une vie,
aussi douloureux
et aussi destructeurs soient-ils.
Une maladie peut rapprocher
une personne de son âme
alors que rien avant n'y est parvenu.
Douleurs, souffrances
sont quelques-uns des visages
que peuvent prendre
les démons dans notre monde.
Pour beaucoup,
ce sont les visages du mal
et certains pensent que le mal
fait plus que de montrer son visage,
qu'il a sa vie propre.
L'idée d'un mal qui parcourt le monde
et que l'homme ne maîtrise pas,
est une idée très désagréable.
L'idée que ce mal
parcourt le monde librement,
de façon indépendante et autonome,
sans être vu la plupart du temps,
est vraie, ce mal existe, il est réel.
Il est dans ma vie.
Il peut nous pousser à faire des choses
que nous ne ferions pas sans sa présence.
Tout au long de l'histoire, l'homme a été
tourmenté par la présence de ces démons.
Pour les catholiques, l'ange
suprême du mal, c'est le diable.
En tant qu'être angélique, Lucifer
qui est le nom véritable donné au diable
fut créé dans le bien
et dans la beauté avec son libre arbitre.
Quand Dieu dévoila
son dessein aux anges,
ils eurent le choix d'obéir
et de faire partie du dessein de Dieu.
Lucifer désapprouva
et dit qu'il ne servirait pas.
C'est à ce moment
qu'il fut banni du ciel.
L'archange Michel expulsa Lucifer du ciel
et ce dernier partit avec
un tiers des anges de Dieu.
La façon la plus terrifiante
dont se manifeste un démon
est quand il entre dans le corps
d'une personne et en devient maître.
Des récits de ce phénomène
extraordinaire parsèment l'histoire.
Les chrétiens parlent
de possession diabolique.
Une affaire récente
concerne un enfant de cinq ans.
Il faut le vivre,
les gens refusent d'y croire.
C'était un enfant né
de parents catholiques irlandais.
Il avait acquis une force démesurée.
Les parents l'avaient attaché
à leur lit et bien qu'il soit très lourd,
l'enfant réussissait
à le soulever d'une seule main.
Il a commencé à avoir un
comportement de plus en plus étrange
et notamment à prononcer
des phrases incompréhensibles.
Les parents ont d'abord
pris cela pour du charabia,
mais on a fini par comprendre
que c'était de l'hébreu ancien.
On a traduit ce qu'il disait et c'étaient
des obscénités et de malédictions.
Des malédictions épouvantables.
Que faire ?
La preuve est faite, il s'agit
d'hébreu ancien et on peut le traduire.
Cet enfant a cinq ans. Que faire ?
Dans la religion catholique,
en dernier recours,
on se tourne vers
le vieux rite de l'exorcisme.
Si les forces de la lumière
semblent être plus actives de nos jours,
les forces des ténèbres le sont aussi.
L'une des tâches qui m'incombent
est de répondre aux demandes
de ceux qui pensent
être possédés par le démon.
De 1960 jusqu'à 1989,les responsables
de notre chancellerie à New York
disaient qu'ils n'avaient
jamais eu affaire à ce problème.
En 1989, nous avons eu deux cas.
Depuis 1990, nous avons
eu pléthore environ 250,
dont que dix pourcent
nécessiteront des exorcismes.
Parce que nous avons pratiqué peu
d'exorcisme entre 1960 et aujourd'hui,
la plupart des exorcistes
ont pris leur retraite où ils sont morts
et ils n'ont pas été remplacés.
Alors à l'heure actuelle,
on a un problème de pénurie d'exorcistes.
En sa qualité de spécialiste
américain de l'exorcisme,
James LeBar a participé
à plusieurs exorcismes extraordinaires.
Le rite d'exorcisme est au
fond une cérémonie très simple,
mais elle peut prendre beaucoup de temps.
Cela consiste à célébrer la messe
puis à prier selon un rite datant de 1614.
Cela consiste à
demander au diable de partir.
Par la puissance de qui Satan
est tombé du ciel comme la foudre.
J'en appelle à votre nom
dans la peur et en tremblant
pour vous demander de
m'accorder à moi votre serviteur indigne.
Votre pardon pour tous
mes péchés et une foi inébranlable
et les pouvoirs
supportés par votre bras puissant
pour affronter avec confiance
et résolution ce cruel démon.
Il y a un combat permanent
entre les forces du bien et du mal.
Les épreuves qui surgissent, qui sont
difficiles, mauvaises, les désastres, etc.
Ils sont une occasion
pour ceux qui ont la foi
de s'élever au-dessus
et de devenir ainsi meilleurs
parce qu'ils ont rencontré le mal.
Bien que les démons
possèdent le pouvoir de faire le mal.
Depuis, les ténèbres s'élèvent la lumière.
La lumière est tellement puissante
que les ténèbres ne peuvent
nous maintenir dans le mal,
sauf si on le permet, car on a peur.
Si on on paralysé,
on n'ira pas de l'avant.
La pire chose qu'un démon peut nous faire,
c'est nous faire souffrir et mourir.
Si nous utilisons cette souffrance
et cette mort comme un élément positif,
comme un moment où
il faut aimer plus profondément.
Il se peut que ce soit
le seul moment de notre vie
où nous aurons vraiment aimé et vécu.
Aussi puissants et vivants
que les anges puissent paraître,
tout le monde n'est pa
convaincu de leur existence.
On trouve de nombreux sceptiques
dans la communauté scientifique,
notamment dans la profession médicale.
Les médecins voient des explications
logiques à ces rencontres angéliques.
L'une de leurs théories est
que les expériences de mort proche
sont provoquées par des substances
chimiques appelées des endorphines.
Le cerveau produit ces
substances proches de la morphine
qui ont des récepteurs
à l'intérieur du cerveau.
Cela a le même effet qu'une forte dose
de narcotiques telle que la morphine.
Qu'elle est l'effet d'un narcotique ?
Il ne repousse pas
seulement le seuil de la douleur,
mais chez beaucoup,
il produit une certaine sérénité
et parfois même chez certains,
un phénomène d'hallucination.
Ces expériences ne se produisent
pas que lorsque les gens frôlent la mort.
Elles se produisent
dans certains types de migraines,
dans des périodes de stress émotionnel,
dans certaines crises d'épilepsie, etc.
Pour le spécialiste
du cerveau que je suis,
cela veut seulement dire
qu'il y a un système dans le cerveau
capable de générer ce genre d'expérience
quand celui-ci est traumatisé
de quelque manière que ce soit.
Ceux qui ont survécu à une mort temporaire
ont souvent vu des choses similaires,
lumières vives, tunnels,
anges et parents décédés.
Que faites-vous de la lumière vive ?
Des parents décédés ? Des tunnels?
Ce que je dis,
c'est que lorsque j'étais enfant,
tout le monde disait que quand
on mourait, on allait au ciel,
qu'il y avait une lumière vive,
qu'on retrouvait les parents décédés
et qu'il pouvait
y avoir Dieu avec sa longue barbe.
Dans nos sociétés occidentales,
on nous raconte ces histoires.
Nous avons été conditionnés à penser
que c'est à cela que ressemble le ciel,
donc si nous avons des hallucinations,
nous voyons au fond
ce que nous espérions voir.
D'autres chercheurs disent
que de nombreuses expériences
de mort proche
ne peuvent s'expliquer ainsi.
Il est un fait que tout ce que nous
vivons a forcément un fond biologique,
je ne crois pas
que cela s'arrête là.
Par exemple, un grand pourcentage de ceux
qui ont eu une expérience de mort proche
ont ressenti
une grande paix intérieure.
Puis, ils ont quitté leur corps et
ils se sont retrouvés ailleurs.
Ils ont pu voir ce que leurs familles
faisaient chez eux, par exemple.
Lorsqu'on interroge la famille
par la suite, on obtient confirmation.
La personne a effectivement vu
ce qui se passait ailleurs.
Les chercheurs affirment
qu'environ cinq pourcent de la population
peuvent être sujettes à des visions.
Les psychiatres affirment que
le système de classification du cerveau
a parfois du mal
à distinguer la réalité de l'imagination.
Une expérience peut être
classée au mauvais endroit
et ainsi, quelque chose
d'imaginaire peut devenir réalité.
Dans les cas que vous décrivez, c'est
une explication possible du phénomène.
En psychiatrie, nous appelons
cela une pensée magique.
Il a été reconnu que
des maladies incurables
avaient été miraculeusement
soignées par une intervention angélique,
mais la communauté
médicale est là aussi partagée.
Il n'existe aucune preuve
que des guérisons miraculeuses
se produisent plus fréquemment
que les guérisons spontanées
prévues par nos chiffres.
Dans ces cas-là,
c'est seulement votre système
de défense immunitaire qui
s'interpose, cela n'a rien de surnaturel.
La science est-elle trop
obtuse pour voir la réalité ?
Ceux qui croient aux anges
disent que certaines réalités
dépassent les preuves scientifiques.
Il y a des choses qui ne seront
jamais prouvées scientifiquement.
Ce n'est pas
qu'elles ne sont pas scientifiques,
mais qu'elles renferment
une vérité psychique,
qu'elles tiennent debout
et n'ont pas besoin d'être validées.
Prenez cette lumière que les gens voient
et qui d'un coup les change complètement.
Ils sont transformés,
leur vie a changé de façon positive,
pas besoin de preuves scientifiques
pour savoir que quelque
chose de remarquable s'est passé.
Beaucoup de choses réelles
ne peuvent pas être mesurées.
L'amour est bien réel, mais on ne
peut pas le mesurer, je l'espère.
On ne peut pas le
mettre sous un oscilloscope
ou un quelconque instrument
et pourtant, il est bel et bien réel.
On le sent et c'est quelque
chose d'important dans notre vie,
donc en ce sens,
les anges sont très réels.
Ce sont des substances,
mais ils sont différents du monde
des substances tel que nous le concevons.
Les scientifiques disent
qu'il est impossible de réfuter
l'existence des anges, mais
que leur travail est d'être sceptiques.
Il y a beaucoup de choses dont les gens
ont affirmé l'existence à un moment donné
et qui sont possibles en théorie,
mais fortement improbables.
Il incombe à la personne d'apporter
la preuve que quelque chose existe
et non à la science
de réfuter son existence.,
car on ne peut jamais
réfuter l'existence de quoi que ce soit.
Rien ne doit être interprété pour exclure
Dieu, les anges ou quoi que ce soit.
Je dis qu'il y a une bonne explication
médicale ou physiologique ou clinique.
Je ne dis pas que ce
n'est pas Dieu ou les anges,
mais qu'il est assez peu probable
que ce soit Dieu ou les anges
ou que les gens voient vraiment des anges.
Pour autant que l'on
sache, il n'y a pas d'anges,
mais s'il y a un Dieu et Dieu a créé les
endorphines et veut que nous les ayons.
Il rend les choses plus faciles
en nous montrant des anges.
Même le scientifique le plus respecté
de notre époque, Albert Einstein,
a laissé la porte ouverte au mysticisme.
Selon lui, il y a deux
façons de mener sa vie.
La première, comme si rien ne tenait
de miracle et la seconde,
comme si tout tenait du miracle.
Dans les années 50,
peu de gens parlent ouvertement
de leur expérience spirituelle,
mais à Las Vegas au Nevada,
vit un homme qui a le courage d'ouvrir son
esprit, de faire confiance à son instinct.
Il comprend que les anges
peuvent revêtir différentes formes
et qu'il a été choisi pour servir
d'ange gardien à ses concitoyens.
Vern a toujours eu cette
merveilleuse aura de paix et d'amour.
Il pouvait parler à tout le monde,
sa voix chaleureuse attirait les gens.
Tout ce qu'ils voulaient,
c'étaient de lui parler.
Les gens pouvaient restent
jusqu'à quatre heures du matin
à la maison
pour parler avec mon père.
Tous ceux qui croisaient le chemin
de Vern devenaient pacifiques et bons.
Ils avaient davantage confiance en eux.
C'est ce qu'il leur donnait, cette
certitude qu'ils pouvaient réussir
tout ce qu'ils entreprenaient.
Même lorsqu'il n'est encore qu'un
jeune homme dans les années 50,
Vern Faulstich a une
présence exceptionnelle.
Il avait un feu intérieur, une sorte de
lumière exceptionnelle qui émanait de lui.
À la minute où j'ai
posé mon regard sur lui,
je me suis dit
que c'était lui que j'attendais.
Policier de métier, Vern aide
les anges à atteindre leur but sur terre.
Il reçoit des messages urgents
lui disant comment sauver des gens
qui se trouvent en danger de mort.
Il s'est réveillé brusquement une nuit.
Il m'a réveillé,
il a dit le nom de quelqu'un
et il a ajouté
qu'il allait essayer de se tuer.
Il a dit qu'il ne pouvait pas aller
vers lui, car il n'en était pas conscient.
Il fallait qu'il attende
qu'il vienne vers lui
et il espérait que ce serait bientôt.
Quelques jours plus tard,
la prophétie des anges se réalise.
Un de ses amis l'appelle,
aide-moi Vern, tu es mon dernier espoir.
Son ami est certain
qu'il va lui donner de bons conseils
et Vern fait confiance aux anges.
À maintes reprises, je l'ai vu
changer, son visage, ses yeux.
Souvent, j'ai vu que
quelqu'un d'autre l'aidait.
Quelqu'un qui parlait
à travers lui, le guidait, l'aidait
à toujours poser les bonnes questions.
Vern l'a vu trois fois, il a réussi à
le calmer et il est toujours parmi nous.
Cet homme est toujours en vie.
On a tous été dans des cas
où on a pu aider quelqu'un.
Vern avait simplement décidé
d'être l'instrument des anges.
Les anges nous montrent le ciel,
ils nous disent de regarder le divin,
regardez ce que vous
pouvez faire en tant qu'êtres.
Regardez le cadeau merveilleux
qui vous a été fait d'être
né ici en tant qu'être humain.
Les missions de Vern
n'ont pas toujours été aussi simples.
Un soir tard, à la fin des années 70,
il reçoit un message mystérieux.
Son ange s'est adressé à lui directement
en lui disant de chercher
le garçon avec la rose.
Après quelques jours, il n'allait pas bien
parce qu'il n'avait pas
trouvé le garçon à la rose.
Je pense qu'il s'attendait
à trouver un garçon au coin d'une rue
ou devant la maison,
avec une rose à la main.
Le jour suivant, Vern
décide de déjeuner dans un café
où il n'est pas allé depuis des années,
il s'installe au comptoir
à côté d'un jeune homme, Mossad.
Peu après qu'il
ait engagé la conversation,
le jeune homme a tendu le bras
pour attraper son verre d'eau.
Vern a remarqué
qu'il avait une rose tatouée sur le bras.
Il s'est dit qu'il l'avait trouvé,
qu'il avait trouvé le garçon à la rose.
Vern a essayé d'en savoir plus sur lui,
mais le jeune homme n'a pas apprécié,
il s'est montré plutôt grossier.
Finalement, il lui a dit
que c'était quoi son problème,
qu'il n'était pas un peu cinglé ?
Vern a répondu
que ce n'était pas la première fois
qu'on le traitait de fou, mais
qu'il avait été envoyé pour l'aider.
Déprimé, incompris par ses parents,
le jeune homme confie à Vern
qu'il veut mettre fin à ses jours.
Verne l'écoute calmement
et puis il le surprend en lui parlant
de sa théorie sur la réincarnation.
Il a fait part au garçon
à la rose de sa théorie sur la vie.
À savoir qu'avant de venir à la vie,
on choisit ses parents et la situation
qui vous aidera le mieux
à accomplir votre mission.
Plus Vern parlait, plus les
yeux du garçon s'écarquillaient.
À un moment, le jeune homme a dit
qu'il ne savait pas si Vern était ou pas,
mais qu'il voyait
que cela lui tenait à cœur.
C'est à ce moment-là que tout a basculé.
Ce n'était pas ce que Vern disait,
mais plutôt que cela lui tenait à cœur.
Espérant que le garçon
a pris un nouveau départ,
Vern le regarde s'éloigner
et il ne le reverra jamais.
Au cours des 15 ans qui vont suivre,
Vern sauvera bien des âmes.
Puis, en 1988, il apprendra
qu'il est atteint d'un cancer incurable.
Quelques mois plus tard,
il mourra à l'âge de 63 ans.
À son enterrement,
des étrangers s'avanceront
pour parler à sa veuve, Kathy.
Il m'a dit qu'il était là
pour dire au revoir à Vern
et pour le remercier de l'avoir
aidé il y a très longtemps.
Sans lui, je n'aurais pas été là,
je n'aurais pas de femme ni d'enfants.
Il y a beaucoup d'anges sur
cette terre et Vern en est un
aux yeux de ce garçon à
la rose et de beaucoup d'autres,
car il a fait ce que
les anges font le mieux,
qu'ils aient une
forme terrestre ou éthérée.
Ils parcourent la terre
en silence et répandent l'espoir.
Lorsqu'on souffre,
le moindre contact chaleureux
peut faire la différence
entre l'espoir et le désespoir.
Le sourire d'un étranger peut
apaiser la tourmente dans nos cœurs,
comme nous connaissons bien,
mais oublions vite le pouvoir
de guérison de la gentillesse.
Pour toutes ces vies
qui ont été touchées par des anges,
il n'est besoin d'aucune preuve.
Pour ceux qui ne croient
pas à l'existence des anges,
il est impossible
d'apporter des preuves.
Les anges restent donc ce qu'ils sont
depuis la nuit des temps,
un mystère sujet à controverse.
Notre croyance dans les anges
semble nous procurer un
réconfort qui ne s'explique pas.
Est-ce une promesse
de quelque chose de plus
ou peut-être tout simplement
notre plus grand désir ?
Un fait demeure,
la quête des anges continuera.